Netflix certainly offers its fair share
of original dramas comedies and animated
series but it's also given stand-up
comedians a powerful new platform the
streaming giant is releasing new comedy
specials at a breakneck pace with the
stand-up game notoriously crowded
Netflix's commitment to putting out
quality specials has been a boon to
veterans and to up-and-comers alike and
it doesn't appear to be slowing down
with a ton of quality offerings to
choose from here are the cream of the
crop the funniest laugh out loud comedy
specials on Netflix right now Ali Wong
hard-knock wife Ali Wong is an extremely
funny woman
but before her debut Netflix special
baby Cobra in 2016
she was relatively unknown that changed
practically overnight as the pregnant
Wang delivered a hilarious set of
profane edgy standup leading to a much
higher profile and an inevitable
follow-up that dropped in 2018 any
concerns about a sophomore slump are
shot down within the first few minutes
of hard-knock wife
[Music]
hard knock is a rapid-fire hour-long set
largely concerned with Parenthood and
pregnancy but even non parents will be
surprised by her insightfulness
hilarious stage presence and crack comic
timing John Mulaney
the comeback kid former SNL writer and
occasional actor John mulaney's 2012
special new in town announced Tim is a
potential force in comedy with his gift
for hilarious turns of phrase which is
an oxymoron and I go can I please go
home no in fact we're gonna frame you
for murder
Mulaney followed that with his 2015
stand-up offering the comeback kid in
which the comic takes on everything from
relationships to pet ownership to Bill
Clinton it's a high impact set densely
packed with gags and it's proof that
Mulaney is never more in his element
than when he's onstage Kevin Hart what
now
Kevin Hart is the rare comic who has no
trouble selling out stadiums or playing
to stadium-sized crowds the comics brash
larger-than-life stage persona makes him
perfect for larger venues as the 2016
concert film what now makes perfectly
clear but it's the contrast of that
persona with surprising digressions into
insecurity and vulnerability that really
makes his stage material tick and while
Hart's been busy carving out a
respectable film career his considerable
talents are arguably best suited for
stand up Hart takes the stage already
holding the enormous crowd in the palm
of his hand
and launches into relatable topics like
male friendships parenting and the
perils of failing to respond to your
girlfriend's text messages fellas let me
tell you something the worst thing that
you could do in life is not respond to
your lady's text message do you hear me
it's a 90-minute long demonstration of
Hart's star power comic chops and one of
a kind presence and if you're not a fan
already
what now will probably make you one she
says so if I got attacked by animal you
wouldn't come out there and help me I
said it depends on the animal if it's a
cat I come out there and kick the cat
Trevor Noah afraid of the dark in 2015
South African comic Trevor Noah was
given a coveted yet nearly impossible
assignment he was tapped to replace the
legendary Jon Stewart on Comedy
Central's long-running series The Daily
Show Noah turned out to be a great
replacement but for a display of just
how formidable his comedic talent really
is his 2016 special afraid of the dark
is more than worth checking out from an
observational bit about New York traffic
through the eyes of a foreigner to a
closing piece about actual fear of the
dark
Noah casually tosses off zingers while
jumping from topic to topic that truck
driver down as he was crossing just
looking at me I got the life I've got
the life
you know I got to like he's a thoroughly
warm and engaging presence making it
easy to see why Comedy Central producers
thought he'd be the perfect fit for
their flagship series here's hoping that
his tenure is just as long and
successful as Stewart's and then it
keeps dropping quality specials like
this one Donald Glover weirdo few stars
are as hot right now as Donald Glover
who began his career as a writer on 30
rock and a main cast member of community
36 you win mr. three yes best known now
for creating and starring in the FX
comedy drama series Atlanta and for his
recent music video this is America
Glover has taken the long road to
stardom in the 2012 stand-up special
weirdo was captured when he was still
relatively unknown and we never went to
Toys R Us we always went to Auschwitz
for kids Home Depot it almost doesn't
seem fair for one guy to be so good at
so many things
but if the acting writing producing and
rapping all happened to fall through
Glover can always fall back on his
stand-up skills bill burr I'm sorry you
feel that way if you've seen the Netflix
original animated series f is for family
then you're already familiar with the
comic sensibility of bill burr family's
creator and main voice actor burr is a
comic who's never funnier than when he
seems on the verge of completely losing
his mind burrs crass approach to comedy
may not be for everyone but his 2014
special I'm sorry you feel that way is
the most OnPoint example of his loud
relentless style burr hammers away a
touchy topics such as gun control
domestic abuse and religion why wouldn't
there be some bearded baby moonwalking
across the lake throwing out bottle this
buckets a shrimp or whatever that
whatever you thick Steve Martin and
Martin Short here's a special sure to
hit smack-dab in the middle of the
nostalgia Center for comedy fans of a
certain vintage in an evening you will
forget for the rest of your life Steve
Martin and Martin Short are back on
stage together for a night of
hilariousness and at times banjos
let's count the awards that you have won
one two three four five six peppered
liberally with asides and references to
their decades of work in television and
film evening doesn't shoot for edgy
humor or gross-out gags some of the
material might be considered downright
safe but you can't deny the simple
pleasure of seeing Martin and short
working the audience like the pros they
are Sarah Silverman a speck of dust
Sarah Silverman blazed her initial path
and stand up by courting controversy her
early stand-up work mind laughs by
contrasting Silverman's girl-next-door
charm with the utterly profane
jaw-droppingly frank nature of her
material and that reputation has
continued to follow her around
throughout her career for 2017 a speck
of dust however Silverman tried a
slightly different tack easing off the
vulgarity and relying on her writing and
comic timing to carry the day and it
worked out pretty well there's still
some risque material in her set but it's
not the star of the show Silverman's
conversational relaxed delivery is front
and center here as she tackles topics
ranging from a recent medical scare to
the insanity of working for a major TV
network
she's a comic who has grown by leaps and
bounds since her stand-up debut and if
speck of dust isn't exactly the
Silverman you're used to it may vary
mark the debut of the silver man who is
destined to be a major stand up player
for many years to come it said I just
spent the morning with a woman who
watched her son get murdered and I was
like you think that's bad
Leslie Jones problem child Saturday
Night Live star Leslie Jones has always
been funny but it's taken the general
public a while to catch on her role in
the 2016 Ghostbusters reboot raised her
profile considerably but her criminally
unseen 2010 Showtime special problem
child put her on comedy fans radar long
before Ghostbusters made her a household
name in keeping with her brash manner
and outsized persona it's an hour of
outrageous anecdotes peppered with
surreal asides on everything from
basketball to an animal conspiracy
against Steve Irwin had an undisclosed
meeting at a location by tree stump in
the woods everybody came even animals
that Steven quit showed up throughout
the set Jones returns to a theme of
self-improvement calling out those who
would judge her by her appearance and
using exchanges with the crowd to help
drive home some of her gags but it's
when those surreal philosophical
ramblings take over that she really
shines Jones is a comic powerhouse with
an incredible knack for playing to a
crowd and perhaps the most underrated
sense of comic timing in the business
and in problem-child
the full range of those talents are
prominently on display Jim Gaffigan
Cinco as one of the most consistent and
cleanest comics working today Jim
Gaffigan is no stranger to Netflix as
you may have guessed by its title
Cinco is his fifth stand-up special for
the streaming service I have one for
each of my five children so hopefully
this is the last one as always Gaffigan
z' deadpan somewhat awkward manner and
keen gift for observation make him
tailor-made for standup even though he's
been successful as a writer and actor
it's obvious that he is most at home on
the stage there's pressure to enjoy
summer right I'm from the Midwest it's
almost a panic
glad there have fun winners coming to
kill us with Cinco he brings an act
that's been honed to a fine point fans
won't find him breaking any new ground
here but when your is consistently
awesome at your job as Gaffigan is
that's not much of a complaint Gaffigan
spends a lot of time taking shots at his
favorite target himself while making
regular asides to offer up hilariously
clever observations some comics are
biting at summer profane some are
downright vulgar but Jim Gaffigan
endears himself to his audience by being
none of the above and proving that you
don't have to be any of those things to
be absolutely hilarious my favor of the
people that carry around the dog in a
bag whenever I see that I was thinking
what an adorable way to let us know
you're crazy